almost anytime we've created something
new in technology we find ways to create
communities around it that was true of
the internet with the news groups and
the bulletin boards and it was true of
the early online services like AOL and
copy serve they were there not just to
give you the news or give you your
horoscope but to allow you to go into
chat rooms into bulletin boards into
ways to sort of form communities of
interest this has been a theme ever
since you know Vannevar Bush and JCR
Licklider the great pioneers of the
digital age said will form virtual
communities will use our digital tools
to form communities of interest when the
world wide web came along in some ways
it was a tiny step backwards because the
web was initially grabbed on as a
publishing medium places like you know
newspapers and magazines or new types of
news services can make beautiful web
pages with pictures and designs and the
community was kind of relegated to a
comment section at the very bottom that
nobody haven't really read but then once
again the street found its own uses for
things and people like EV Williams who
created bloggers and some you know
Swarthmore College sophomore named
Justin Hall who started keeping a weblog
and talking about all of his sexual
misadventures and everything else
suddenly we got this notion of blogging
in a blogging community and on top of
that we've had all sorts of social
networks being built whether it's
Facebook and whatsapp or Twitter we
always seem to want to connect to each
other
it hasn't diminished our desire to meet
up physically as well in fact meetup is
a good example that service of saying
you know if you find friends in the
digital world you actually sometimes
want to get together with people in the
physical world but whether it's physical
or virtue virtual our digital tools sort
of grab us and say let's form
communities I think that technology has
always been driven by engineering but
the next phase is connecting the
creativity to it the creative industries
and I can see now evolving this merger
of
live-action role-playing games and other
forms of games and virtual realities
like oculus rift and and many other
types of tools that will connect music
and multimedia and the fashion
industries and journalism industries to
this notion of community formation to
Wikipedia's to crowdsourcing so we could
have collaborative new forms of arts and
entertainment just like you know novels
came along when we got the printing
press and you know different things came
along when we got television or
different ways of having entertainment
and media I think we will invent new
forms of media that will tend to be more
community oriented than television or
print is that will tend to be more
collaborative where many people will be
working together creating a role-playing
game or creating some community around a
topic creating like a wiki that can do
almost anything discuss any topic play
any game I am really loving to see how
this collaborative interaction
interactive crowdsource creativity is
starting to flourish especially when you
add on top of that a layer of something
like Bitcoin that allows sort of easy
payments and allocating maybe the
royalties from something that's sourced
and created by a crowd of people not
just one person I think the writing of
books is going to change quite a bit in
the digital age because even with this
book the innovators I put a lot of it
online I put it up drafts on places like
medium.com so people could write their
comments people could add their own
anecdotes their own tales and so when I
was writing about the hippie movement in
California and how it related the
personal computer Stewart Brand who had
been the publisher of the Whole Earth
Catalog all of a sudden he's online and
saying here's some here's some
information about the demise Party of
the Whole Earth Catalog so I put that in
the book so I can imagine narrative
nonfiction books that are biographies or
histories instead of being written by
one author could be curated by a No
but written by dozens hundreds maybe
thousands of people who are all involved
in a particular process they can each
put up their videos or notes their oral
histories or diagrams write their
stories tell their stories videotape
their stories and put them all up and
they could be curated into sort of a
crowd-sourced living book that you can
explore and interact with not just read
what only the author wanted to tell you
it was the narrative